Today's video, I'm going to show you three
pretty cool tricks to enhance your application
using ngrok.
We'll be using ngrok
to protect an endpoint,
to restrict an endpoint using geolocation facilities,
and to improve the security posture of our
application.
Let's have some fun.
Okay.
So, let's start with the application
first.
Now I've kept the application super,
super simple.
It's just here
to enable us to dive in to ngrok
features.
Now that's maybe just my excuse for giving
you an API with black text on a
white background.
But what we have here is a Deno
application
configured with a router and some Prometheus metrics.
We create a path counter so that in
each route within our application or API, whatever
you wanna call it, and we increment this
based on the path that we hit.
As we hit the home page and hello
world, we increment. As we hit slash howdy
and howdy world, we increment.
These metrics will also be exposed on slash
metrics.
And one of the first things that we
want to do with ngrok is just protect
the metrics endpoint from unsuspecting traffic.
We then listen or bind our application on
local host 127001.
So this is a private by default application
on port 8,000.
Now as private as I run it on
local host and as we push it to
production and to maybe a container or Kubernetes,
it would be private to the pod unless
we hook an extra infrastructure concerns to expose
that to the world.
Now because we're gonna be showing off ngrok,
what we need to do first is run
this application and
expose it with ngrok.
So here, I have a README file with
a d n r run command that allows
me to run my API.
Like so.
I'm then using ngrok locally to say, let's
expose port 8,000 over HTTP
on my domain, rawcode.ngrok.dev.
Now I'm not gonna guide you through the
installation of ngrok locally. You can use Next
Shell,
your system package manager, a container,
or whatever you like.
For me,
I'll do run block.
So now let's head over to our web
browser and see what our wonderful application
looks like.
So let's go to localhost port 8,000.
And here we have
hello, world.
We can now change that to Howdy,
and we get Howdy World.
One more time, we go to metrics, and
we see that we've had both of these
pass one time.
We can also go to
ngrok.dev
like so.
And I accidentally went to metrics, so let's
go to route,
go to howdy,
and then pop back to metrics, where now
we've had both pages of the application twice.
And if we refresh the local one, you'll
see that these are the exact same application.
All we've done is use ngrok to make
this available on the public Internet.
Now as cool as that is, ngrok has
been around for over a decade, and we're
all fully aware that ngrok makes this workflow
trivial.
So
let's take a look at a recent feature
added to ngrok cloud,
traffic
policies.
Okay. So,
again,
just like a moment ago, ngrok is running.
I can browse around via
Rawkode.ngrok.dev
between the home page and Howdy.
Here, I have a GCP Cloud Shell where
I can also curl
ngrok,
Rawkode.ngrok.dev,
and I see hello world,
Howdy,
and, of course,
metrics.
What I want to do now
is stop ngrok
and show you the second version of this
command.
Here,
we're going to
run it just as we did before, the
exact same command. However, we're going to add
our traffic policy file.
And now if we hit run,
we can sell browse
locally.
However,
from GCP,
the connection is immediately rejected.
Why?
Well, let's take a look at our traffic
policy file.
Here, I said,
on a TCP connection,
we wish to restrict the IPs
with
enforce.
We could set this default to test out
new policies. However, for this simple example, we're
gonna enforce it by default.
And these are the two IP I p
v four and the infamous I p v
six,
for my machine
on this network.
Meaning, if anyone else tries to access our
application, it's going to fail. But, of course,
what's the point now? Right? It's the exact
same as if I just ran it locally
bound to 127001.
Now the secret sauce of traffic policies is
the common expression language.
We can actually modify
this
to only restrict a certain endpoint.
So let's go take a look at the
ngrok documentation.
This is the traffic policy page, which is
currently in preview, but we like to fly
things on the edge and unstable as often
as we can. It makes things more fun.
We can pop down to restrict IPs
where we'll see a nice example of how
to do this, very similar to what I
have done in my application.
But we want to tailor this
using
expressions.
We have access to a whole bunch of
variables within the common expression framework,
which has been enriched or augmented by ngrok
to provide even more context. If we click
on connection variables here, you'll see that we
only have a access to a small number.
Now that's just because we were using a
TCP connection
and not HTTP.
So we come to HTTP
and overview.
We can click on expressions.
We can click on request
variables.
And now we have the understanding
of an HTTP
request. Okay. So let's scroll down,
and then we see request
URL
and request
path.
Oh, that's port.
Path.
So we copy this,
and what we want to do is push
actions down,
but correctly formatted, and drop in our expression.
We can update this to be slash metrics.
So now what we're saying is if the
request path starts with metrics,
restrict it to these IP addresses.
So we can kill our ngrok process, head
back to the README, and say run.
Like so.
Now if we head back to the service,
we can still get to howdy,
we can still get to hello,
and we can still see
metrics.
If we pop over to a GCP cloud
shell,
we can run h t t p s,
Rawkode,
ngrok.
Dev, we get hello,
we get howdy,
but we don't get metrics.
And we can actually see the request was
blocked
by the endpoint's
IP
restriction.
Sweet.
Okay.
Now we're gonna try something a little bit
different.
I've added a new endpoint to our application
slash u k that says, hello, u k.
We're gonna add a geo restriction to this
endpoint so that only the people in The
UK can see The UK page.
Heading back over to the traffic policy documentation,
we can click on expressions overview,
and we'll see that we have access to
connection
geo variables.
Now these actually are available on TCP and
on HTTP.
However, we wanna send a response over HTTP,
so we're going to continue using on HTTP
request.
We click on this. We can see that
we have access to city, country, country code,
latitude, radius, etcetera, etcetera.
What we want to do is filter by
country.
So we'll copy this expression
and head back to our traffic policy doc.
Here, we can add a new
expression
like so,
making sure we got the right formatting.
And I'll set this to United
Kingdom.
Next, we wanna add our actions,
and we can add a type
deny
with a config
of status
code
404.
We can just make it look like this
page does not exist to anyone outside of
The UK.
Now to find the deny and disconfiguration,
you can just click on actions,
deny,
and you'll see that status code is the
only accepted property,
and there are plenty of examples throughout ngrok's
documentation.
Great work, ngrok.
Heading back over here, we can go to
our README,
make sure our application is running,
and run ngrok again.
We head over to our browser.
It looks like it's already tried to refresh,
and we're getting a four zero four.
Now
that's because we didn't restrict the path in
which we want to block the country.
And I'm kinda glad that it has blocked
the country even though I am in The
UK because it means that we have to
debug this and work out how it represents
The UK as a country name.
What we'll do is say that we only
want us to apply to slash UK and
we will stop ngrok.
We'll hit run,
go to the browser,
and our howdy works, but our UK
does not.
So let's modify this. And instead of doing
a deny, we're going to do something else.
We're actually going to send a custom
response.
We can configure this much like we did
with the deny.
And to get the properties that we need,
we'll head back to the documentation
and click on custom response.
We can continue to set a status code,
only this time
we can set content
and
headers.
So status code, it's gonna continue to be
four zero four. The content will be some
HTML string.
And the headers,
we probably want to set
content
type,
and we'll leave that as text plain.
And we'll just say, sorry,
This page
is only
available in The UK.
You are from
Congeo
country.
Now we know that this should work because
it tells us here in the documentation that
the cell interpolation is enabled on this field.
So let's go back and run ngrok again.
We can head back to this page and
refresh.
And it tells me that I am ending
in United Kingdom,
which just makes this all a little bit
more amusing
for you.
Okay.
So let's head back over here.
And, of course, there's always something silly.
We want to block when the country is
not
The United Kingdom.
So let's kill that first process,
rerun ngrok,
head back to the browser,
and refresh. And, of course, we get hello
UK.
So
let's run curl
htpsRawkodengrok.dev/uk.
And now our Cloud Shell tells us that
it cannot access this website because we are
in Belgium,
but we haven't affected
any other page.
Perfect.
So I hope you see just how powerful
traffic policies for ngrok can be, and we've
barely scratched the surface.
Go explore the documentation where you'll find examples
of
JWT validation
for your endpoints.
You can disable and secure TLS ciphers,
enable compression,
and add and remove HTTP headers to request
all
through a simple YAML interface.
I hope you enjoyed this video. Please remember
to thumbs up and share the video with
your colleagues.
Until next time. Have a great day.